in california with camallo harris and
her new yes probably
and now also today with a 10 p.m
lockdown of 8.5 million which is
happening in california
right now welcome because somehow you
won't get the the covid virus
if it's 10 0 or 10 0 9 59.
ladies and gentlemen pull out your bingo
cards and get ready to check off the box
that box that says
welcome to the nightmare dystopia 8.5
million people are being ordered to stay
home ahead of a california statewide
orders
10 000 people hospitalized 22 000 daily
cases are recorded 145 deaths in 24
hours
this is in the bay area and it is just
expected to escalate
but i but i must stop there is some good
news california sheriffs have come out
saying f you okay we're not going to do
it ain't going to happen i'd love to
hear it how do you
how do you break your oath of the
constitution some
surprisingly there are a lot of cops who
do some sheriffs but not all the
sheriffs
there still will be a lot of pointless
ignorant police officers that don't have
a backbone that don't have a soul
that will enforce these orders with the
full might of the police state and
one thing we have to understand here
people changed their lifestyles they
lost their jobs they lost their
businesses
they lost their freedoms their kids
can't go to school anymore they
eviscerated and destroyed the working
class and any prosperity any a
ability of freedom for people to have
because of a lockdown and now
it pretty much didn't work but they're
not enough to lock down
again do you know the quarantines
quarantine
is the closing in of sick people and
preventing sick people from spreading so
what do you call it when instead of
doing that they lock everyone in their
martial law
essentially martial now let's play a
game michael flynn recently tweeted out
the we the people convention
calling on donald trump to invoke
extreme wartime powers
essentially declaring a light martial
law having a new election and we saw
lynn wood we saw sydney powell we saw
many trump supporters echo this
and the collective screeching from the
left it's
happening there's memes going around
it's the political compass right
and you've got the authoritarian left
the libertarian left and the libertarian
right and they all have shocked and
scared faces
and then you have this like really doofy
looking guy with a maga hat saying
martial law good and then in the middle
it says michael flynn calls for martial
law
and then the libertarian left side is an
anti-for-looking guy with a bunch of
guns saying we told you so
and i think this is really really funny
because they have been enforcing martial
law on this country for a year
and you supported it and now you're mad
that people are saying
hey donald trump needs to stop this and
something must be done about it yeah and
they voted for it and we're going to
have a lot more of it with a joe biden
presidency and i'm still shocked how
last year we literally went from storm
area 51
they can't stop us all so right now
let's have
christmas and thanksgiving together uh
they can't arrest us all when
we're lock us in our homes yes lock us
in our house absolutely insane area 51
the event was pretty fun but that's a
different subject oh ho
center homes kevin yeah yeah terrible
protest chant i just made it up
i don't like it go with it i don't know
but we're seeing a lot of resistance
from some sheriffs
we saw a significant protest in staten
island
we're seeing slowly people kind of wake
up and realize that it's kind of
hypocritical to allow black friday
but not thanksgiving and and people i
think i i i might be naive but i think
there's a larger kind of feeling of
discontent
of anger and frustration at all these
politicians who set up all these rules
and don't follow
them but listen listen listen
conservatives aren't complaining about
peaceful protests from black lives
matter
in the sense that they're protesting
they're complaining about the hypocrisy
of demanding lockdowns and then
protestings and then protesting
but there's nary a conservative who's
saying these people are gonna get us all
sick they shouldn't be protesting no
they're saying
you have a first memorize to protest but
how dare you say we should be locked
down and you get to go outside
meanwhile on the left they're saying
we're gonna go celebrate and dance in
the street for joe biden
and then in staten island when the cops
arrest this bar owner and a couple
hundred
just regular people not trump supporters
maybe some of them maybe they
but regular people in the community came
out with flags protesting
i'm seeing all these lefties say these
people are going to kill us
i'll tell you what the problem is right
now in this country those people who are
saying this
they don't care about you they don't
care about the law
or the rules or any kind of moral or
ethical standard it's we get power
and you can go to hell and that's
what that's that's what they're giving
us when i see regular people say
please we're struggling and dying we
can't do this anymore and they say
shut your mouth get in your home and
drop to your knees
we're gonna go party that's a powder cag
that is about to explode
only a matter of time 100 agree and uh
we went we went to the gun shop the
other day
yeah and i was like i will take that
whole shelf of ammo and that whole thing
wasn't that much left
and the guy was like i understand yeah i
kept telling my friends and family
members in
june it was everything by the way buy
everything you can i mean i'm shocked at
what you guys have here
compared to new hampshire it's
absolutely gone nothing i mean
i'm just well let's let's let's let's
put this into context so we went to
we went to a i don't want to give out
details because i don't want to you know
drag anybody
we went to a gun store they don't have
that much ammo a lot of odd caliber
bullets things that like i was like do
you even have guns for this stuff
three times four times even ten times
and it was like as
what i was paying for in june it was
like two boxes per
per like different you know ammo type
except for the 12-gauge stuff that i was
like i went nuts and i was like well
that's still readily available because
right you know that's still something
that people can get but when it comes to
nine millimeter
six you're paying an arm and a leg it's
absolutely crazy i mean
for for you know nine hundred bullets
five five six i was paying a couple
hundred dollars that's a thousand bucks
a thousand bucks for 900 bullets and i'm
like
and the thing is it's not going back to
normal soon that's the thing people
think it's going to go
back to normal it's not i love how the
guys were just like yup
like it's not totally it's totally
normal like someone comes in and they're
like
there's not that much to buy because i i
when i
wa so dude it's no joke i bring this up
in in
earlier this year and i said i don't
want any guns in my house and then covet
happened the pandemic stuff happened the
stalker happened
oh yeah i had a whole bunch of stalkers
as well for sure for sure but like
looking at the stores being picked clean
and like we we had a walmart only like a
mile or so away and i'm like
we're really close to this place and
there's they're like there's there's no
food people are running in and seizing
all the toilet paper and stuff i'm like
we got to take care of ourselves and i
even had a cop
advise me and and we were really we're
in a small suburb so the playstation
wasn't that far away and he was like
you need to answer your door with a
shotgun when someone comes you know so
that got me thinking but it wasn't until
the riots went nuts and i heard the
helicopters
i went out and bought a bunch of guns
but here's the thing they had no ammo i
remember i went in and i was like i was
talking to the guy and i said i need
45 auto and he goes one box and i'm like
it's 50
50 rounds he's like all i can do so i've
been to three or four different shops
there's one shop where they said you get
one of each box
and it's crazy too because the 22 it's
like 50 it's a little tiny box i'm like
what am i going to do with this and
you're lucky
i know i know that's why when we went to
that one store i was like
i will take it all and they're like no
limit sir we understand yes here's a box
it was marked up pretty heavily but it
was only but they're going to keep going
up
uh and we have to understand here this
is something that a lot of people are
finding
very troublesome i mean even from like
an investment point of view if you
bought bullets and firearms in in june
and july
you you could sell it you'd be making it
to make a crap ton of money
uh just on that initial investment and
and some people legitimately are
but there's a lack of a lot of this
stuff because people are buying it
whenever they can because they know
either
one something major is going to happen
two they know that there's going to be
an administration that's going to try to
take it away from people
um remember that remember the story
about the red flag laws when they
started coming out
where someone could basically report you
as being unwell and the cops show up to
your house and say we're seizing your
guns
there was a story i think it was
baltimore some guy gets a the
cops up to his house he he says you know
who they say with the police he opens up
and they say we're here to take your
guns and he says
not a chance the cops fight with them
cops shoot and kill them these there are
people who will absolutely
say no to the police who try to violate
the constitution
now that's scary it's i understand it
for sure what's scary about it is
we are dangerously close when we know
for a fact these states are violating
the constitution why because supreme
court's already ruled in states like
michigan and pennsylvania
and then says that california are still
doing it or when the supreme court sides
with
worship religious institutions under the
first amendment did you
did you read i think it was gorsuch his
opinion
there's no version of reality where
you're you can have tanning salons and
liquor stores remain open but people
can't go to church
that that was bold yeah but they issue
that and then what does cuomo say
so what we'll do it again and can you do
it one other thing that people have to
realize here when you look at the
strictest
toughest most unfair lockdowns that rob
people of their livelihoods they are
mainly happening in democratic cities
where people don't have the right to
defend themselves and are not
armed you look at what happened in
canada and australia where there was
recently
gun legislation that limited people's
ability to defend themselves
what happened the canadian government
and australian government are absolutely
having a heyday with just
making up whatever made up decrees not
even based off on the science
not even any logic but they're locking
people down in extreme ways arresting
people
meanwhile allowing black lives matter
protests check this out
but check this the other day uh when we
had destiny here
he said we need a two-month lockdown
everybody should get paid
and the issue was we ended up coming
back to it and i said didn't we already
lock down
and he was like not nationwide but hold
on europe they locked down
they closed their borders and it all
came back why did it come back
well because we eased the restrictions
so you're saying that no matter what we
do
covet is here to stay there's nothing we
can do about it we can't live this way
we can't there's it's physically
impossible to stay this this way
unless they just want people to die they
want people to starve become evicted
get depressed commit suicide dependent
on government uh go
but but no but listen yes to an extent
being dependent on government
but at a certain point there's no food
on the shelves unless someone puts it
there or makes it exactly and if no one
is working there is nothing to be given
to
people politics is a popularity contest
we got stupid people
running in the show as well as
government mandates that literally
slaughtered
chickens pigs got rid of and thrown out
did you see vegetables and fruits that
were available for everyone
but all of those i mean i was in touch
with some farmers across the united
states they were ordered
destroy everything you have the supply
chain has been cut
this is the best thing you could do it's
absolutely insane and now there's food
shortages and now
we have to understand the effects of
these lockdowns are not leading to more
suicides like we just saw in japan
in japan more people killed themselves
than died from
uh kovid 19 and around the world
especially in
desolate places in third world countries
hunger is becoming more of a rapid
epidemic but we keep
we keep being told by these politicians
no we're going to do another lockdown it
didn't work the first time but it's
going to work now oh we're going to do
more masks they didn't really work but
we're going to do them more now oh we're
going to wait until the vaccine comes
again everything the politicians have
been saying about this have been
absolutely wrong and i think it's
extremely dangerous coming forward
with the establishment yes everything
the establishment said because
trump said school should remain open yes
and they said he was nuts he wanted to
kill your kids
now we're and they said he was nuts when
he tried to shut down travel from from
china
and they were keep they keep going back
and forth there's no consistency there's
no logic
and a lot of times they just lie to you
through their teeth they're telling you
just hold on a little bit longer
everything's going to be fine just
just give us a few more weeks just give
us 100 days of math thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8 p.m so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you